empecemos por hablar qué tanta sintonía
puede haber entre vaiden y Petro en este
encuentro Bueno un gusto estar con
ustedes y con toda la audiencia Pues nos
encontramos finalmente con unas
relaciones que son tradicionales entre
Colombia y Estados Unidos durante
muchísimo tiempo predominó lo que se
denominó acá localmente
seguimos Mirando al norte Sin embargo
tal vez el diálogo viene siendo un poco
más entre comillas equilibrado al menos
así ha sido El Siglo 21 al ratificarse
que Colombia es un país Aliado de
Estados Unidos y esto no ha cambiado sin
embargo por supuesto biden es un es un
gobernante de línea
de partido demócrata Y tenemos un
presidente progresista como es Petro en
Colombia ahí pueden haber alguna
sintonías eventualmente frente a cambios
que pueden haber en la agenda
internacional pero de fondo Estados
Unidos es un país que representa la
democracia liberal y Petro no es Un
gobierno que presentó un gobierno que
tiene también que respetar esa línea
hasta donde le es posible bueno José
usted mencionaba que Colombia sigue
siendo un Aliado de Estados Unidos pero
también hay una marcada diferencia sobre
todo en materia de políticas de drogas y
también respecto a Venezuela dos temas
en los que Gustavo Petro se ha alejado
de la visión de Joe biden Cuáles son
estas diferencias bueno el cambio
primero es que el énfasis en la
represión no viene planteando hace
tiempos el gobierno de Pedro es decir un
cambio que se viene hablando No
necesariamente hacia La regulación o la
legalización de las drogas Pero si ya
nuevos enfoques que eh disminuyan la
represión directa frente a los agentes
campesinos y llamémoslo los impactos
frente a la naturaleza de los sectores
donde se produce la cocaína como tal en
Colombia y sino más bien enfocarlo
justamente en la interdicción y en lo
que ella mismo la represión legal y
policial contra los agentes
narcotraficantes como tal es decir las
mafias en ese sentido entonces ahí hay
un cambio un poco más enfocado hacia eso
y más progresista también con la idea en
que Petro buscaría justamente dentro de
su enfoque de la paz Total que haya una
renovación de las lógicas económicas que
sostienen el negocio Entonces en ese
sentido hay una mirada nueva
efectivamente Petro la está planteando
sin sin temer sin temor alguno Y es que
entonces el problema tiene que tener una
posición mucho más proactiva desde la
visión del consumo de la sociedad
norteamericana algo que muchos
académicos han señalado en el pasado y
por supuesto entonces tener un enfoque
menos represivo hacia el campesino y
hacia el productor para que
eventualmente puedan ayer haber haber
otros tipos de sustituciones en en la
materia económica que sostenga a esas
familias y por ahora Petro está haciendo
prudentes estar tratando de no no
disminuir esa interdicción y mientras
tanto bailen escucha porque ahí viene
entonces que habrá habrá que dar tiempo
si este tema de la pasta total Avanza o
no Entonces yo creo que biden estás
escuchando más que conversando con Petro